>> Geraldo: HOW THE WORM HAS
TURNED THE ONE SYMPATHETIC AND
FRIENDLY MEDIA FURIOUS WITH JOE
BIDEN, THEIR OLD PAL, AFTER HE
AVOIDED THEIR QUESTIONS AND
AIDES TOSSED THEM OUT OF THE
ROOM LIKE A SACK OF ROTTEN
POTATOES AFTER HIS MEETING WITH
BORIS JOHNSON.
THE MEDIA WAS TRYING TO ASK
ABOUT MULTIPLE ON GOING CRISES
LIKE THE BROKEN BORDER, THE
TALIBAN, AFGHANISTAN.
THE BRITISH LEADER ON THE OTHER
HAND MORE THAN HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS.
OUR PRESIDENT?
NOT SO MUCH.
>> WOULD IT BE OKAY IF WE HAD A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS?
JUST A COUPLE.
>> GOOD LUCK.
>> ASK HIM THE QUESTION.
>> Geraldo: I HATE THAT CHAOS
THERE.
YOU'RE THE EXPERT, DANA.
WHAT IS THE BETTER COURSE OF
ACTION WHEN THINGS ARE REAL --
WHEN YOU'RE UP TO YOUR NECK IN
CRAP, IS IT BETTER TO AVOID IT
OR BETTER TO DEAL WITH IT?
>> Dana: OWN IT.
YOU'RE THE LEADER OF THE FREE
WORLD.
YOU JUST GAVE A SPEECH ABOUT
HUMAN RIGHTS AND DEMOCRACY.
FREEDOM IN THE PRESS IS PART OF
THAT.
YOU'RE SITTING WITH BORIS
JOHNSON, THE SECOND MOST
POWERFUL MAN IN THE WORLD AND
YOU'RE NOT GIVING HIM A MOMENT?
YOU MADE HIM LOOK BAD IN HIS ON
COUNTRY.
YOU DENIED PEOPLE TO TRAVEL IN
YOUR OWN COUNTRY.
THE WHITE HOUSE TEAM TOLD THE
BRITTS WE'RE NOT GOING TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS.
BORIS JOHNSON IS SITTING THERE
AND HE'S LIKE WE CAN DO THAT,
RIGHT?
SURELY WE CAN DO THAT.
WE HAVE TO BE SO RUDE TO HIM.
I WANT TO KNOW, WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE RETURN TO NORM'S CROWD?
THE DEMOCRACY DIES IN DARKNESS
BRIGAD
BRIGADE?
WHERE DID THEY GO?
I UNDERSTAND THE PRESS IS MAD.
THE PROBLEM IS THEY DIDN'T START
COMPLAINING DURING THE CAMPAIGN
WHEN THEY COULDN'T HAVE -- COULD
COMPLAIN A LITTLE BIT.
THEY TREATED HIM WITH KID GLOVES
AND NOW THEY'RE MAD.
ONE OF THE THINGS THE WHITE
HOUSE DID TODAY, THEY BLAMED THE
BRITTS FOR SURPRISING THEM WITH
TAKING QUESTIONS.
IN A RETURN TO NORM, TRADITIONAL
MEETINGS WITH THE FOREIGN
LEADER, YOU GET TWO AND TWO.
THAT'S THE RETURN TO NORMAL.
>> Geraldo: WHAT ABOUT THAT
BIDEN SEEMS TO HAVE GONE FROM
THE A GRIEVED VICTIM TO THE
PERPETRATOR OF THIS OBJECT  --
>> Greg: HE'S GETTING ORNERY,
OLD.
EVEN THE STAFF HAS A LOW
APPROVAL RATING OF THEIR
PRESIDENT.
IT'S LIKE -- THIS IS THE FASTEST
DISINTEGRAING PRESIDENT IN
HISTORY.
I FEEL LIKE I'M WATCHING A TIME
LAPSE.
I DON'T HAVE SYMPATHY FOR THE
REPORTERS.
THEY COLLUDED TO SUPPRESS THE
HUNTER BIDEN STORY THAT WOULD
HAVE DISQUALIFIED JOE BIDEN THAT
WOULD HAVE ARE REVEALED THE
E-MAILS WERE TALKING ABOUT CHINA
AND GETTING MONEY OUT OF AN
ADVERSARY.
TRUMP WAS RIGHT.
DIDN'T MATTER.
THE REPORTER REFUSED TO DO THEIR
JOB.
NOW THEY HAVE TO LIVE WITH THE
GUY THAT DIDN'T TWEET, DIDN'T
MAKE MEAN JOKES.
BUT HE'S SUCH A NICE GUY THAT HE
DRONED A BUNCH OF KIDS.
THAT'S ON THE PRESS.
THEY ELECTED THIS GUY.
>> Geraldo: THE PRESS BEHAVIOR,
DOES HE GET ANY SLACK BECAUSE
THEY WERE SO FALLING OVER EACH
OTHER TO BE OBNOXIOUS?
>> Jesse: THAT WAS OBNOXIOUS?
THAT WASN'T OBNOXIOUS.
THAT WAS TAME.
THE PRESS CREATED THIS MESS.
THE LAST PRESIDENT WAS ON TRUTH
SERUM.
WE HAVE FULL ACCESS, RAW, UNCUT.
WHAT DID THEY DO?
THEY KILLED THE GOLDEN GOOSE.
THIS GUY GAVE THEM RATINGS AND
BOOK DEALS AND CLIPS.
THEY COULDN'T TAKE IT BECAUSE
THEY WERE SUCH PARTISAN HACKS
FOR THE DEMOCRATS THAT THEY
COLLUDED WITH THE BILLIONAIRES
TO DESTROY HIS PRESIDENCY.
NOW WE HAVE A STIFF, RIGHT?
HE DOESN'T GIVE THEM RATINGS,
HE'S BORING.
THE PRESS IS BORED OUT OF THEIR
MINDS.
SO BIDEN HAS NO RESPECT FOR
THESE PEOPLE.
BIDEN KNOWS THEY'RE IN HIS
POCKET.
HE DISRESPECTS THESE CONSTANTLY.
WHATEVER.
I'M NOT GOING TO TALK TO YOU.
IT HELPS HIM.
HIS HANDLERS, IT'S JUST A WAY OF
THEM PROTECTING JOE FROM
HIMSELF.
THEY KNOW HE'S SHOT.
HE CAN BARELY COMPLETE A
SENTENCE.
THE MEDIA PRETENDS LIKE THEY'RE
UPSET.
WE'RE GOING TO SEND A LETTER.
SO WHAT?
THEY DON'T CARE.
IT'S A FAKE AGGRESSION.
THEY LOB SOFTBALLS AND JOE WILL
ABUSE THEM WITH SILENCE AND
ACCESS AND GOES ROUND AND ROUND.
>> Geraldo: THE AREN'T I CAN'T
DISAGREE WITH JESSE, THERE'S AN
EXAMPLE MORE EGREGIOUS.
THE INDICTMENT OF MICHAEL
SUSMAN, THE CAMPAIGN LAWYER
WORKING FOR HILLARY CLINTON.
HE WAS INDICTED.
HE FUELED THE RUSSIA COLLUSION
HOAX.
THE RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
CLEARLY HILLARY CLINTON'S
CREATION AND THE PRESS IS NOW
TOUCHING IT.
IT'S LIKE IT'S A NONSTORY.
AFTER THE IMPEACHMENT OF A
PRESIDENT --
>> Jeanine: WHAT I SAW TODAY, I
SAW THAT THEY GET VERY UPSET.
THE WHOLE POOL MARCHES OVER TO
JEN PSAKI'S OFFICE AND THEY FILE
A COMPLAINT, WHICH I THINK IS
REALLY HYSTERICAL.
I HAVE COME TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT IT'S JEN PSAKI SAYING YOU
HAVE TO -- DON'T TALK TO
ANYBODY.
TAKE THIS REPORTER FIRST, DON'T
ANSWER ANYTHING FROM THAT
REPORTER.
YOU KNOW WHAT JEN PSAKI SAYS?
HER RESPONSE IS LOOK, I'M NOT IN
A POSITION TO OFFER AN IMMEDIATE
SOLUTION.
THE TRUTH IS THE PRESIDENT
ANSWERS QUESTIONS EVERY DAY.
THAT IS HER RESPONSE.
THAT'S HER SOLUTION, EXCEPT HE'S
NOT SPOKEN ABOUT THE DRONE, NOT
SPOKEN ABOUT THE BORDER, HASN'T
SPOKEN ABOUT ANY OF THE ISSUES
THAT ARE CONCERNING TO THEM.
MAYBE NOW START TO GET UPSET AND
REALIZE, YOU KNOW WHAT?
HE WAS CONDESCENDING WHEN BORIS
JOHNSON SAID I WANT TO ASK A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS.
HE SAID OH, GOOD LUCK.
THAT'S CONDESCENDING.
THEY CAN'T GET AN ANSWER FROM
HIM.
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS.
THAT'S FIRST AMENDMENT.
YOU KNOW WHAT --
>> Dana: THEY WERE NICER TO THE
TALIBAN.
>> Greg: DON'T YOU FEEL LIKE THE
MEDIA IS TERRIFIED OF JEN PSAKI?
>> Geraldo: SHE'S THE MOST
COMPETENT PERSON IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Jesse: SHE HAS TO BE.
THAT'S NOT SAYING A LOT.
>> Dana: SHE'S GOOD AT HER JOB.
>> Jeanine: SHE CAN SHUT IT
DOWN.
>> Jesse: SHE'S FIELDING